how's it going everyone
venom is right around the corner less
than a month away now and as we get so
close to it Sony's going to start
promoting it a lot more their marketing
is going to be taken up a notch
which is good news for us because we'll
get more info about the movie more
photos more TV spot trailers so all
around a good thing before we get into
the latest look just a reminder I'm
still doing the infinity war blu-ray
giveaway if you'd like to enter for your
chance to win a copy all you have to do
is be a subscriber like this video and
comment below with your thoughts and
your favorite superhero
so Tom Hardy took to his Instagram and
just posted this awesome poster of venom
I love this poster there's so much
detail in it and I think that detail is
where it needs to be one of the things
that I do like is that I feel like
they're trying to stay true to the
comics so Venom's teeth and his tongue
this poster in particularly places a lot
of emphasis on his teeth and his tongue
which they should because it's such a
huge part of who the character is
especially in the comics so I think the
detail on the teeth is done very well
they're kind of like chaotic and random
much like the character and it seems
like the tongue is kind of the main
thing of this poster it's really right
in the middle again such a huge venom
thing and this really is his thing is
tongue such a main characteristic of
venom and I'm so glad that they're at
least trying to get it right there's
also this other poster of venom that is
relatively new which is half then I'm
half Eddie Brock also done extremely
well super cool love it
so there's your new look at venom with
the new poster we got let me know what
you think in the comments below and
again the infinity war blu-ray giveaway
continues all you have to do is be a
subscriber like this video and comment
below with your thoughts and your
favorite superhero thank you all so much
for watching
Wolf Wolf
[Music]
[Music]